well she had me until she said clean hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by billbar
and we'll be looking at 22 year old
lifestyle influencer molly may but first
let me tell you about my sponsor
buildbar so my regular subbies know i
talk about building snacks and meals
with my hunger crushing combo in mind
and that means lots of fiber healthy
fats and protein so build bars are
really a staple for supplying the
protein piece and bonus they taste like
chocolate because they're made with
actual chocolate hello okay so today's
snack in flavor
where are we going where are we going
i'm feeling like a holiday so i'm going
with the coconut
pow
this
just hits different she's good
and she's got 17 grams of protein super
tasty on its own and paired with a
source of fiber-rich carbs like oatmeal
or fruit and a little healthy fat action
from maybe some nut butter or some nuts
and we have a super super satisfying
balanced snack so if you want to give
belt bars a try check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
also feel free to pause the screen or
look at the description including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are new here welcome don't forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
bell and hit me up over on instagram and
tick tock abby's kitchen also shout out
to the hubs for getting me this awesome
cup i don't know if you can see
but it says my favorite word over
and over
and over again and i'm feeling it today
and apologies for the voice i am a
little bit congested thanks to everyone
in the house getting me a little sick
but
the show must go on all right folks
let's hop in and take a look at what
molly may eats in a day i've been having
i've been getting so many questions
asking me to film a video about how i've
kind of changed my life how i've started
eating cleaner started exercising more
how i've just really done like a 360 of
my life about 18 months ago i was in a
really really really terrible place with
my body i'd really really fallen off and
that was mainly because i was just so
busy at least it was like work work work
work since i have changed so much and
made such an effort to be healthier and
exercise more i have noticed such a
significant change in my moods in the
way i am each day in how early i get up
in the morning like my sleeping pattern
our sleeping patterns were horrendous i
used to order delivery at like three in
the morning okay so
my long-term stubbies probably all held
their breath when they heard the word
clean and while i do not love that i do
appreciate that molly seems to have
found a way of eating that you know
feels good to her and also can discuss
it outside the context of changing her
body better moods energy levels and
sleep are all super high value
motivators for maintaining healthy
behaviors long term i have a nice
peppermint tea to
settle my stomach okay so i've discussed
the benefits of peppermint in my video
on bloating cures right here but yes
peppermint has long been used as an
anti-spasmodic to help soothe and calm
the gi tract and while well-steeped
peppermint tea may be strong enough to
help most of the evidence that we have
is on peppermint oil or peppermint
capsules which can be used to treat
benign digestive symptoms like bloating
and abdominal cramping now she also
mentions using peppermint tea when she's
feeling knots in her stomach from
anxiety in her november video titled
let's talk and all of this makes perfect
sense to me now we've talked here about
the brain gut axis before on my channel
but basically this is the communication
between your brain and emotional state
of mind and your digestive system hence
the term you know butterflies in my
stomach or as like a more crude example
when you're so scared that you your
pants
did you just
hey all my ibs friends i feel you on
that in any case the combination of
those gut soothing properties plus it's
like comforting warmth makes peppermint
tea a great pick for nervous tummies how
i have a protein shake for breakfast and
i have filmed myself making it before
but just so you guys know that's why
i've gone back to recently having a
protein shake because it just really
sets me up well for the day it keeps me
full until lunch um and it's just
something i can have before i go and
work out because i cannot work out on an
empty stomach i would literally feign
and we don't want that chocolate protein
shake in the nutribullet i i've just
been having a chocolate protein shake
recently sometimes i have a strawberry
one and i put berries in it or sometimes
i add like a banana so molly suggests
she's having a simple protein shake
pre-workout because she absolutely
cannot work out on an empty stomach so
in her case i think it's quite clear
that fed exercise is the best way to go
like she said passing out on the
treadmill is not a good look
as for what is better a meta-analysis of
46 studies found that pre-exercise
feeding enhanced longer duration
exercise performance but not shorter
duration while fast exercise helped
increase fat oxidation having said all
that just because it's somewhat
established that fat oxidation increases
after fasted cardio over time other
research suggests that it actually
doesn't seem to have an impact on body
composition so bottom line do what feels
best to your body as for molly's choice
in a pre-workout snack she showed
herself actually preparing the smoothie
in another video which turns out it's
just protein powder and some water
though she does say sometimes she adds
in some fruit if she feels like she
needs something more substantial and
protein is great for satiety we always
talk about that here but it's not the
ideal pre-workout fuel especially if
it's a heavy cardio day ideally we would
want to see a carb based meal so
toast oatmeal fruit granola with or
without protein depending on if she's
you know able to have a protein based
snack afterwards post workout so i'd
love to see that fruit worked into that
smoothie more often my stomach is still
fully not back to normal from my
endometriosis operation well i need to
justify on my stomach doesn't look
extra time today but yeah that is fine
okay so i'm very sorry to hear about the
endometriosis diagnosis and surgery if
you guys don't know endometriosis is
when the endometrium which is the tissue
that usually lines the uterus grows
outside of that uterus which can cause
very painful periods and sex digestive
issues and also infertility it's
actually the leading cause of
infertility so as a fellow infertility
warrior this is near and dear to my
heart now this is a relatively low
invasive surgery but that doesn't mean
that there isn't some swelling
afterwards as they do need to make some
small incisions to go in and remove the
tissue as for diet recommendations the
research in this area is evolving but
some of the early evidence suggests
reducing trans fats red meat gluten and
other high fodmap foods and consuming a
diet packed with antioxidant rich fruits
and veggies research also suggests that
supplementing with antioxidants like
vitamin e c zinc n a and curcumin in
turmeric while maintaining optimal
levels of vitamin d may also help now
this is a really really really big topic
so if you want a video on eating for
endometriosis definitely leave me a
comment below
[Music]
i've kind of like got an understanding
now what i like to have in my fridge
things i can grab quickly like if i'm on
the go and
things i try to like avoid having in my
fridge now that
gets me into bad habits okay just very
quickly i get that a lot of you feel
that you can't have certain foods in the
fridge or in the pantry in order to
maintain healthy habits and for some of
you that might be just what works best
but if you have a trigger food that you
feel you can't control yourself around
and that having it in the house results
in like a big binge i challenge you to
see what happens if you give yourself
unconditional permission to eat that
food my professional experience tells me
that in most cases it will lose its
allure and power if you have a trigger
food that you want to learn how to rob
of its power
definitely check out my hunger crushing
combo series right here
so i got myself a coke zero i've ordered
a chicken salad and some hummus and
pizza bread i need the carbs it's a
really cold day
and the carbs are necessary the humus
and pita bread this is like
not a naughty habit because it's really
not that unhealthy but i do love myself
a bit of humor so this is the chicken
salad as you can see it looks so so nice
okay i love this meal and i agree with
molly you know greens with grilled
chicken post workout probably isn't
enough so aside of carbs it just hits
different am i different we mean great
so we ideally want to get a three to one
ratio of carbs to protein post workout
and this right here is checking all of
my hunger crush and compound boxes so we
got protein in the chicken we got fat in
the dressing fiber in the salad carbs in
the pita and the hummus has got a little
bit of all the things and no this is not
a naughty habit in my books nor would it
be a naughty habit to order like a
burger and fries but that's beside the
point i've just got from the supermarket
and i'm having some party rings these i
don't know why everyone asks me when i
say i like party rings still because i'm
22 years of age but these actually hit
differently and they're actually not
that bad for you there's only like i
mean you get about two party rings in a
pack they're
that big same size as my eye um
but really good little snack okay this
must be a uk thing and i am mad about
that because they look like a party to
me now i don't think we need to
necessarily call out any cookie as being
that bad for you but if she means that
they're not high calorie i agree like
these are relatively light little
biscuits as the brits call them so three
cookies have just 84 calories and less
than nine grams of sugar and they
low-key look like the kind of cookie of
my childhood tea party dreams so to all
of my uk followers please ship your girl
a little box over the pond so i can try
them i actually do like to use
vegetarian mints just because i have
this fear of like biting into meat and
having like gristle in it or bone dinner
it doesn't really look
michelin star let's just say okay so i
love this for a super simple meal i am
all about culinary shortcuts especially
if you're alone and you don't want to
make like a whole meal from scratch so
leaning on some pantry staples like the
microwave rice and like pasta sauce it's
a great way to get a balanced meal on
the table fast plus we've got some
protein in the vegan mints fiber and
carbs in the brown rice and some fat in
the cooking oil and cheese and she did
mention that she prefers vegetarian
protein because she's kind of scared or
nervous of meat grizzle but it's
actually a really great choice for
endometriosis as well since research has
linked red meat consumption to
endometrial diagnosis so one study found
that women who consumed two or more
servings of red meat per day were 56
more likely to suffer than those who
consumed only one so i do think it is
smart to focus on more plant-based
options like this and i'm going to make
myself a cup of tea and i'm having these
chocolate biscuits it's super super late
right now but it does it smells like
pure lavender
like
the sort of thing you spray on your
pillow before you go to bed i mean
obviously i don't have to make you
sleepy cheers guy
okay so earlier on in the vlog she
mentioned that she bought this tea
because she sometimes finds that she
struggles with sleep and this one claims
that it will knock you out with its
blend of apple pieces lavender and
chamomile so let's fact check that so we
know lavender oil has been studied for
its role in promoting sleep with
research suggesting small to moderate
benefits when inhaled compared to a
placebo but they haven't seen the same
effect yet with tea as for chamomile
while the research is inconsistent one
study found that folks who drank
chamomile tea for just two weeks
reported better sleep quality than those
who didn't now i'm not sure a cup of tea
will knock you out but the ritual alone
may be calming and soothing and
therefore may actually help as for the
chocolate biscuits there's likely not
enough actual chocolate in that to cause
any major interferences with sleep but
if she did want to optimize the bedtime
snack she could pair those cookies with
a few kiwi fruit which research suggests
can actually reduce the time to fall
asleep by 42
i always just think little changes are
better than no changes if you need to
make changes at all if you want to make
changes
just
do small things every day that that make
a difference don't go into like trying
to work out four times a day and eat
nothing but chicken and rice like it's
just not it's not obtainable um set
yourself small goals and yeah anyway i'm
not going to preach because it's
literally 2 a.m okay so first of all i
agree with the suggestion 100
but pro insomniac tip do not vlog before
bed
nothing about being a youtuber is
relaxing but it definitely does not help
promote good sleep if you're constantly
thinking about work and you're actually
doing work aka filming while you're in
bed this is why you guys don't see a lot
of this kind of content for me
personally it's just too invasive for my
mental health and speaking of invasive i
want to touch base on another risk of
the business aka her robbery essentially
molly's home was robbed and literally
everything was stolen which is no doubt
incredibly traumatic when she spoke
about this from her new apartment she
said it's really really hard to find
that balance of sharing so that you guys
want to keep up with my life and see
what i'm doing but then also keeping my
life private so that i stay safe and i
think i potentially maybe lost that
balance um i
have to be 20 billion times more careful
now um about the things that i'm sharing
house tours and things like that like
for obvious reasons are just an absolute
no-go so this is so terrifying that this
happened to molly but it is a really
scary reality for content creators or
influencers who share intricate details
of their lives online and this is again
why i'm very careful about what i show
here on my channel it's partially a
modesty thing because you know i know
that i'm blessed and i really don't
think it's becoming of me to gloat but
even more important than that is that i
want to protect my family so i really
hope that molly can find some peace of
mind in the new space and also that she
can figure out a balance for her work
that still feels safe for her and on
that note let's talk about the stats so
on this particular day molly's consuming
around 1300 to 1400 calories which does
seem inadequate for most women of her
size and activity level i would love to
see a more substantial breakfast meal
especially if it's also serving as like
a pre-workout as well as some extra
protein and or healthy fats in her
sweet-based snacks now i do appreciate
however that her meals are pretty
accessible simple and generally not
accompanied by any pseudoscience sure
there's a little bit of clean eating
talk and she does occasionally label
certain foods or ways of eating as maybe
bad or not so bad but i do think this is
kind of part and parcel with diet
culture these days and i'm not seeing
any outrageously dangerous suggestions
so we're gonna wrap that up here folks
that is all that i have for you guys
today a big thank you again to buildbar
for sponsoring if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what or who you'd like
seeing your view next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]